Ngay mục mùa thống bây, thu tương thái lan và phê tông tăng Xin Aua Trà đến bố, tôn trọng quy định đình chỉ bù của tỏ hiện pháp,
và sẽ dải trình trong mấy lắm ngày về một đích của định đàn với chủ tịch thượng viện cáp uống chia yệu không khun xanh.
Bà khẳng định lỗi dung của gọi chỉ nhằm giảm các tháng bình dưới, bà vệ bị sĩ thái lan, không có i đô cả nhân.
Pháp biểu được bà phê tông tăng đưa ra chỉ và tiến sau khi tỏ hiện pháp thái lan quy định đình chỉ chỉ bù tổ tưởng của bà.
Bà mấy sáo thượng dịch thái lan cũng gạo buộc bà bị phạm đạo đức nhiên trong vì gọi ổng hung xanh là chủ và chỉ chích từ lạnh của đối gần của 2 của nước nhà trong gặn nghiệm viên gió dị.
Mặc dù vậy, tuả vận cho phép bà tiếp tục giữ trước bộ trường và nguồn bản giải trình trong vòng mấy lắm ngày.
Pháp biểu chức bà chế bà phê tông tăng cầm ơn những người ổng hộ, xin lỗi này dần thái lan bị hành động có thể gây khó chíu và khẳng định luôn đặt lựa íc đất nước lên hàng đầu.
Mặc gặm gát tức tục công hiện trên công việc bụ trường và ngoài trong thời gian chờ cái lợp của tỏa and tổ giao.
trong thời gian bà phê tông tăng bị linh gì, phó tụ tưởng kiếm bụ trường dào thông vật tả thái lan,
Surya Trung Rung Rung Rung Rung Rung Rung Rung Rung Rung Rung Kỳc sẽ đảm nghiệm quyền thu tưởng.